con calles inundadas de publicidad
proselitismo en pandemia alemania se
encamina elecciones federales el próximo
26 de septiembre un proceso marcado por
la incertidumbre de quién sucederá
merkel para el próximo periodo
son las impresionantes y cansados telón
de la calidad creo que es un poco
diferente con todos los candidatos es un
poco complicado de hecho era fan de
merkel y tengo que admitir que no sé qué
va a pasar después
esta es mi tercera elección o más bien
la segunda y por supuesto que no conozco
más a nadie que la señora merkel como
canciller
los alemanes decidirán entre diversos
aspirantes con una variedad biológica
que participaron este jueves en el
último debate y donde los principales
candidatos coincidieron en resaltar la
importancia que tiene alemania para
europa y el contexto internacional
camps consent fields hay algunos
principios que son importantes para
nosotros incluida una unión europea
fuerte porque de lo contrario no jugamos
un papel eso incluye la cooperación con
eeuu magnet ingush a cannes south toda
europa está analizando cómo será el
nuevo gobierno alemán porque alemania es
un estado importante en europa hay
distingos scouts para algunos
especialistas estas elecciones se
enfrentarán al electorado más joven con
sus mayores por el tema del medio
ambiente y reina la expectativa de si
las multitudinarias movilizaciones a
favor de la conservación se manifestarán
también en las urnas